this is pressure Locker can you figure
out this problem that Google used as an
interview question if the probability of
seeing a car on the highway in 30
minutes is 0.95 what is the probability
of seeing a car on the highway in 10
minutes
assume a constant default probability to
be more precise when the problem says
seeing a car that means seeing at least
one car the assumption of a constant
default probability means there is a
constant probability rate of seeing a
car for example there's no rush hour
traffic during one of the intervals this
means the probability of seeing a car
during a time interval can be treated
like a coin flip can you figure this out
give this prom a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution we'll get started by writing P
as equaling the probability of seeing no
cars in 10 minutes
what is the probability of seeing no
cars in 20 minutes this is the
probability of seeing no cars in 10
minutes followed by another event of
seeing no cars in 10 minutes we're
treating each of these like a coin flip
so the probability of seeing no cars in
each 10-minute interval is equal to P
which means the probability of seeing no
cars in 20 minutes is equal to P squared
we then have the probability of seeing
no cars in 30 minutes is equal to the
probability of seeing no cars in the
first 20 minutes times the probability
of seeing no cars in the next 10 minutes
which is equal to P squared times P or
equal to P cubed so now what is the
probability of seeing some car in 30
minutes this is 1 minus the probability
of seeing no cars in 30 minutes this
will be equal to 1 minus P cubed we're
given in the problem this is equal to
0.95
we can then rearrange this equation to
get that P cubed is equal to 0.05 which
means P is equal to the cube root of
point O 5 which is approximately 0.368
we now need to calculate the probability
of seeing at least one car in 10 minutes
this is equal to 1 minus the probability
of seeing no cars in 10 minutes which is
equal to 1 minus P which is equal to
approximately 0.632 so it's an
approximately 63% chance that you'll see
at least one car in 10 minutes did you
figure this out thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker and if you like this video please
check out my books there are links in
the video description